this is a Christmas song we wrote for
people you can't normally share
Christmas songs with baby you and I
haven't seen eye-to-eye on many things
this year we've had our share of
speights plenty of Facebook fights and I
generally don't want you near but when
it's holiday time and the bells start to
shine and I think about what you say
I force a smile on my face and I skip in
my pace and wish you a Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas to all my haters
Merry Christmas
oh yeah my
name online be raping
you see singing a jar dream
Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas
tablet rings around the Christmas
get back to our normal
no we're not quite the best of friends
you say you hate to look at my face and
most times of the year I'm glad to dis
up here when you and I are in the same
place but when Christmas is in town I
hope Santa comes round and church that
Brown
I hope friends gather near a drink
ginger red beer and lab all day big all
those reindeer it's nice to all mater's
Merry Christmas
I hate me online berate me
I hope we know really
Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas
my dress
get back to our
say this although once it's tomorrow
you made me feel really
while I try to stay strong so we get out
you've always been a dick someday soon I
hope you'll go to the moon and stay
there the rest of your days and what
normally I mean your face up I might on
and say
very Christmas to all my haters Merry
Christmas
Oh am i hate me online berate me I hope
it does
Merry Christmas
get back to normal
get back to our garlic lock
mom yeah please please come in got some
fruit please come in please great to see
you great to see you mm-hmm
[ __ ]